Çeviri: Nadya Alasad
Gözden geçirme: berat güven
Şimdi efendim,
12 yaşındayken ilkokulu bitirdim.
İlkokulu bitirme hediyesi olarak
babamdan bir bisiklet istedim.
Almayacağını biliyorum
çünkü hem mali durumumuz
o kadar iyi değil,
en azından benim bisikletimi ayıracak
bir parası yok,
bir de gergin bir adam, sinirli bir adam.
Ben yine de cesaretimi topladım,
istedim o hediyeyi. "Olur" dedi.
Çok şaşırdım, olur-
babamdan böyle bir cümle.
"Olur ama şöyle yapalım", dedi,
"Yan tarafta bir inşaat var.
Sen orada git kendine bir iş bul, çalış.
Para biriktir, üstünü ben tamamlayayım,
alalım bisikleti" dedi.
Herhalde bir eşek şakası bu!
Yani arkadaşlarım yazın top oynayacak
gezecek, edecek, oynayacaklar,
ben orada çalışacağım!
Ama sırf inattan sabaha kadar ağladım.
Sabah kalktım,
"Tamam" dedim "Çalışacağım.
Çalışacağım." Gittim hemen
inşaatın müteahhidi ile konuştum.
Dedi "Bir yarın gel bakalım,
sana ne gibi bir iş buluruz?" dedi.
Ertesi gün gittiğimde
elimde bir kova kireç,
sönmüş kireç, bir tane fırça.
Bir ustanın yanına verdiler beni.
Ben yan taraftaki 4 katlı
8 daireli apartmana astar çekiyordum,
o çocuk halimle ve tabii
boyum bir yerlere yetişmiyor,
gözüme kireçler kaçıyor,
gözlerim şiş, kan çanağı gibi.
Yani her gün akşam,
annem ağlayarak pansumanlar yapıyor.
Babamın umurunda değil,
çalışsın öğrensin diyor.
Bak ne güzel çalışıyor, diyor.
Bütün bir yaz, ben o apartmanın
astarını çektim
o usta ile beraber, bayağı bir çalıştım.
Sonra iş bitti, müteahhide gittim.
Dedim ki "Ben paramı istiyorum."
"Tabii" dedi, paramı verdi.
Oho, bisiklet parası çıkmış.
Harika! Babama bile ihtiyaç yok,
o bisikleti alırım.
Akşam babamın gelmesini bekledim,
büyük bir vapurla.
"Al" dedim, "Param hazır,
yarın gidip bisikleti alacağız."
O kadar eminim ki
şimdi "Alalım alalım da" dedi
"Yaz tatili bitti. Okul açılacak, kar,
kış, yağmur, çamur.
Sen bu bisiklete binemezsin... yani.
En iyisi biz bu parayla
önümüzdeki yıl alalım."
Anladım ki o bisikleti bana aldırmayacak,
yani ben parayı biriktirdiğim halde
bana aldırmayacak
ve sinirden ağlamaya başladım
ama dedi "Dur!".
"Bütün yaz boyu çalıştın,
yani bu kadar emek verdin.
"Şöyle yapalım" dedi.
"Para senin,
bu parayla istediğin şeyi
alabilirsin" dedi.
Para benim, istediğim şeyi alabilirim,
harika! Çok hoşuma gitti,
istediğim her şey, her şey.
İlk hafta sonu Kızılay, Ankaralılar bilir,
Ülke Alan Pasajın'daydık,
kendime çok güzel bir forma aldım,
bir şort, tozluklar lastikli,
kramponlar çivili ve bir de
deriden bir futbol topu.
Şimdi küçümsemeyin çünkü
o dönemlerde deriden futbol topu almak,
hele bizim gibi böyle
dar gelirli aileler için müthiş bir şey.
Ve mahalleye geldiğimde
mahallenin kralı benim çünkü topum var.
O topla istediğim takımı ben kurabilirim,
istediğim takım benim olur.
Top bende, güç bende. Ve ben o yaz işte,
o yaz boyunca, emeği tanıdım.
Emeğin ne olduğunu anladım,
emeğimin gücünü fark ettim.
Bu çok hoşuma gitti, gerçekten.
Yıllar sonra babam öldüğünde
ama yıllar yıllar sonra,
annem itiraf etti; babam o bisikleti
bana özellikle almamış,
özellikle aldırmamış.
Çünkü yine Ankara'yı bilenler bilir,
Dikmen, Ankara'nın Dikmeni
çok dik bir yerdedir, çok yokuştur.
Dermiş ki hep anneme-
öyle değilmiş yani-
"Hanım" dermiş
"Ben bu oğlana bu bisikleti alırsam,
bu oğlan deli, bu oğlan yaramaz.
O yokuştan aşağı inmeye kalkar,
gider orada kamyonun altında kalır,
ölür mölür, başıma bela olur.
Ben ağlayacağıma, bırak
bisikleti yok diye o ağlasın" dermiş.
Dolayısıyla benim hiç bisikletim olmadı
ama ben o yaşımda emeği öğrendim
emeğimin kıymetini, değerini öğrendim,
emeğimin gücünü öğrendim.
O günden beri de, en değerli şeyim emeğim,
elimdeki tek silah emeğim.
(Alkış)
Sonra üniversite yılları başladı.
Bir taraftan fizik okuyorum, bilim yani.
Öbür taraftan tiyatro ile uğraşıyorum,
sanat yani.
Ama kafam karışık, hem de çok karışık.
Sanatçı mı olacağım, bilimci mi olacağım,
fizikçi mi olacağım?
Fizikçi olsam ne iş yapacağım?
sanatçı olsam, oyuncuların hali ortada.
Kafam çok, çok, çok karışık,
ne yapacağımı bilemiyorum.
Bu arada, benim bir dedem var.
Kendisinin ağzından bir tek bile
Kürtçe kelime duymadım
ama lakabı 'Kürt Hasan',
Güneydoğu'dan kağnı ile gelmişler.
o yüzden olsa gerek; Kürt Hasan
ama bir tane Kürtçe kelime duymadım.
Kürt Hasan gördüğünüz gibi
bir kamyon şoförü
ilkokul mezunu bile değil
ama mesleğin de hayranı, mesleğine aşık.
Her sefer bittiği zaman,
o kamyonunun motorunun
son vidasına kadar temizler,
gıcır gıcır yapar.
Asla çocuklarını ve torunlarını
kamyonunun yanına yanaştırmaz
çünkü "Sizler okuyacaksınız,
benim gibi kamyon şoförü
olmayacaksınız" der.
Ama her akşam garajdan eve gelirken
pırıl pırıl giyinir;
takım elbisesi, ayağında pileli
duble paça pantolonu,
sonuna kadar bağlanmış gömleği
üzerinde kaşkolu, kasketi
ya da fötr şapkası,
mevsimine göre pardesüsü, paltosu
ve gıcır gıcır parlayan
iskarpinleriyle eve gelir.
Eve gelir gelmez hemen
annem paltosunu alır,
dayılarım kaşkolunu kasketini alır,
anneannem ayakkabılarının bağını çözer.
Hiçbir şey konuşulmadan
akşam yemeği için sofraya oturulur.
Yemek duası dışında
hiçbir şey konuşulmaz, çünkü günahtır.
Ancak yemekten sonra çay, kahve,
işte meyva seansı sırasında
dedem günün raporunu alır, herkes
ona ne olduğunu ne bittiğini anlatır.
Sonra torunların yatma vakti.
Kız torunları öper,
onların saçlarını okşar,
erkeklere asla, elini bile öptürtmez,
dokunmaz bile.
Biz tabii hep buna sinir oluruz.
Meğer öyle değilmiş, o bizi gece severmiş.
Biz uyurken saçımızı okşarmış.
Çünkü erkek çocuk şımarık olmasın,
cıvık olmasın, dermiş.
Sonra başka bir adamla tanıştım.
Cüneyt Gökçer, hocam.
Dedemle hemen hemen aynı yaşlardan.
Cüneyt Gökçer, tiyatronun,
büyük tiyatronun altında yapılan atölyede,
demir atölyesinde,
teneke bir taç, sarıya boyanmış,
altın sarısına, kafasına takmış.
Efendime söyleyeyim, belinde yine
atölyede yapılan tahta bir kılıç,
at kılı- kuyruğundan yapılan
saçları ve sakalıyla
her akşam sahneye çıkıyor
ve "Ben kral, bilmem bilmem kimim!" diye
bağırıp duruyor, ortada çığırtıyor.
Şimdi, kafam iyice karıştı,
ne yapmak gerek?
Bir gün Cüneyt Gökçer
elinde bir tahta bavulla geldi
bildiğiniz tahta bavul,
içini bir açtı,
içinden o güne kadar oynadığı
bütün rollerin fotoğrafları.
Krallar oynamış, padişahlar oynamış,
profesörler oynamış,
işadamları oynamış, berduşlar oynamış,
çeşit çeşit yüzlerce fotoğraf.
O zaman düşünmeye iyice başladım.
Şimdi, ya bu adam gibi yaşlandığımda bile
başka insanlar olmak, sahnede olmak vardı
ya da dedem gibi tek bir tip,
tek bir karakter, tek bir insan.
Dedim, "Emek benim değil mi? Benim.
Emeğimi istediğim yere
kullanabilir miyim? Evet.
Emek benim silahım mı?
O zaman bu iş emek vermeye değer.
Ben bu işi seçiyorum" dedim.
Zaten bizleri belirleyen de
yaptığımız seçimler değil mi?
Ve ben o gün oyuncu olmaya karar verdim.
Fiziği ve dedemi bir kenara koyup
Cüneyt Gökçer'in peşinden gittim.
Evet şanslıydım, çünkü hem fizik okudum,
bilim okudum hem tiyatro okudum,
yani sanat okudum
ve bu ikisinin ortak yönü
her zaman çok dikkatimi çekti.
Çok farklı görünebilir ama ikisinin de
ortak yolu, çıkış noktası,
ilerleme dinamosu, hep aynı soru:
Ya öyle değilse?
Hep bu soru.
Bu soruyu sormak her zaman
benim de işimin bir parçası oldu
çünkü bir oyunu oynarken,
bir oyunu sahnelerken,
hep bu soru sorarız; ya öyle değilse?
Ya başka bir şeyse?
Ama bu soruyu sormak
biraz cesaret işi, biraz cesaret ister,
biraz karanlık ister, geleceğe
ulaşma arzusuna içinde barındırır.
Ya öyle değilse? Ya öyle değil de,
ya dünya düz değil de yuvarlaksa?
Ya öyle değilse?
Ya atom parçalanabiliryorsa?
Ya öyle değilse,
ya ölüm diye bir şey yoksa?
Ya da zaman sadece bir hayal
ve illüzyondan öte ise?
Daha da ileriye gidebiliriz.
Ya yaşadığımız bütün bu hayat
bir bilgisayar oyunu ise?
Ya tanrı yoksa?
Bütün bunları sormak
gerçekten tehlikeli sulara girmek,
başınızı belaya sokacak sorular demektir.
Ama medeniyetimizi geliştirenler
hep bu sorunun peşinden gidenler oldu.
Ya öyle değilse, ya başka bir yolu varsa?
Ya başka bir çözüm,
başka bir bakış açısı varsa?
Ya kimsenin aklına gelmeyen
o muhteşem fikir, o en iyi fikir,
bir dolabın arkasına düşüp kaldıysa? Evet.
Bundan, bilim adamları yıllarca önce,
milyonlarca yıl önce
evrenin oluştuğunu, peşinden dünyanın
ve yaklaşık 150 bin yıl sonrada
insan denilen yaratığın
dünyaya geldiğini ispat ettiler
ya da iddia ediyorlar.
Insanoğlunun yaptığı tek şey ve ilk şeyse
toprağı sahiplenip
birbirini kesmek olmuş.
Mülkiyetle başlayan zorba yönetimlere
tarih boyunca karşı gelenlerse
hep bilim insanları, sanatçılar
ve devrimciler olmuş.
Hepsi, ya öyle değilse
şüphesine sahipmişler.
Sümer'den, Mısır'a,
Hipokrat'dan, Euripides'se
İbni Sina'dan, Kopernik'e,
Shakespeare'e, Çehov'a, Brecht'e
Da Vinci' ye, Einstein'a, Steve Jobs'a,
Aziz Nesin'e kadar
bir sürü bilim insanı, bir sürü filozof,
bir sürü sanatçı bu soruyu sormuş:
Ya öyle değilse?
Yeni çözüm yolları üretmenin
soru sormaktan geçtiğini
bunlar herhalde çok, çok,
çok iyi biliyorlarmış.
Şüphecilik ile paranoyanın,
gerçeği aramakla,
komplo teorisi üretmenin
arasındaki farkı da çok iyi biliyorlarmış.
Şaşmaz bir güvenle,
içsel bir güdüyle
ya öyle değilse sorusunu sormaktan
hiç vazgeçmemişler.
Ya öyle değilse sorusunu sormak
gerçekten cesaret işidir.
Zaman zaman ağır bedeller ödemek
zorunda kalınabilir
ki nitekim de öyle olmuştur.
Çünkü bu soru birçok iktidarı,
birçok normu,
birçok yerleşik düzeni
kızdıran sorulardır.
Ya öyle değilse?
İnsanlık tarihi bu sorunun
yanıtını arayanların
kanlı yazgılarıyla dolu.
Bu sorunun üzerinden felsefe yapmak,
bu sorunun üzerinden sanat yapmak,
bilim yapmak gerçekten bazı cezaları
göze almak demek.
Sokrates'ı idam edenler,
Giordano Bruno'ya işkence yapanlar
Sivas'ta aydınlarımızı yakanlar,
Uğur Mumcu gibi gerçekleri söylemekten,
yazmaktan, korkmayan, çekinmeyen,
onlarca insanımızı acımasızca katledenler.
Nazım Hikmet'i, Mandela'yı
hapislerde çürütmeye niyetli olanlar
Che Guevara'yı kurşuna dizenler,
Şeyh Bedrettin'i,
Pir Sultan Abdal'ı asanlar
işte bu sorudan korkanlardır.
Onlar... (Alkış)
...bu soruyu sormaktan korkanlar,
gelişmek, ilerlemek,
bilinmezi çözmek istemezler.
Bedeli ne olursa olsun,
bu soruyu sormaktan korkmamalıyız.
Gerçekten bu soru
hayatımızın dönüm noktasıdır.
Çünkü bir tane hayatımız var,
onu da istediğimiz gibi yaşamalıyız.
Sorular soralım, şüpheci olalım,
yaratıcı olalım.
Dağın ardında çöl var diyenlere
hemen inanmayalım.
Gidip kendimiz görelim,
belki de o dağın ardında bir çöl yok.
Yani eğer yoksa da, olsun,
spor yapmış oluruz,
dağa tırmanmış oluruz, fena mı?
Belki o dağın ardında gerçekten çöl yok.
Belki bunu bize söyleyen insan
o dağa çıktı
ve çıktığında yanlış bir mevsimdi
ya da bakar kördü görmedi
ya da bize yalan söylüyor.
O yüzden kendimiz görmekten
hiçbir şekilde sakınmayalım.
Çünkü deneyimlemekten
kimseye zarar gelmez, evet.
Şüphe gerçekleri ortaya çıkartır,
ilerlememizi sağlar.
Eski köye yeni adet getirme,
ya da insanın başına ne gelirse
ya meraktan gelir.. ya meraktan gelir'e
çok fazla aldırmayalım.
Ya öyle değilse sorusunu
sormaktan hiç vazgeçmeyelim.
Çünkü niye? Ya öyle değilse?
Ya öyle değilse? Ya 19 Mayıs'ta
Samsun'a çıkan Paşa
vatan haini değilse?
Ya bugün vatan haini diye suçlananlar
vatan haini değil de
onları suçlayanlar gerçek vatan haini ise?
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)